Facebook Twitter Google all of them have
received billions of be billions tens of
billions of dollars in direct subsidies
and tax breaks over the last five to ten
years so are those are those still
private entities should they just be
treated like you and me in our living
room corporations and businesses whether
it's your brother-in-law's one-person
startup or the biggest company in
America also have speech rights they're
taking our tax dollars big time and then
telling us what we can and cannot say on
their social media platforms what we say
when we say that social media networks
ought to act like the state and only
punish things that are outside the First
Amendment is that social media networks
ought to be speaking the way we want
them to the soho forum is a monthly
debate series held in manhattan that is
moderated by Jean Epstein and
co-sponsored by reason
it features topics of special interest
to libertarians in the series aims to
enhance the social and professional ties
of people within the New York City
libertarian community thanks to Tom
yangste we are trying a West Coast Soho
forum here so hopefully we'll have that
same experience so as many of you know
we're celebrating 50 years of reason
this weekend and I will you know let me
start by thanking you guys for your
support and interest over not just the
years but the decades we can't do what
we do without your help without your
interest without your readership so
please give yourself a big hand and what
I'm gonna do now is I'm going to explain
the proposition under debate the
participants the rules of the game and
we'll go from there
first I want all of you to pull your
cell phone out and go open your browser
and go to Soho vote.com
we're going to take a second here sohe
vote.com you can vote yeah please vote
and you're gonna see when you go there
you're gonna see a screen that says it
has the proposition and it's the
pre-debate vote this is a what is called
an Oxford style debate so we polled the
audience before and after the
proceedings and the winning side is the
side that has pulled more people to its
position so that the proposition is like
universities social media platforms such
as Twitter Facebook and YouTube should
only remove speakers and participants
who are making true threats or inciting
violence take a vote yes/no undecided
and we're gonna let those tabulate for a
little bit and while we're doing that
then we're gonna close the voting and
we'll come back to it afterwards but
please do go to Soho vote.com and enter
what you what your position is starting
out so we are debating whether or not
social media platforms such as Twitter
Facebook and YouTube should when should
they remove speakers the two speakers
tonight who I'm about to introduce both
agree with the broader libertarian point
that these are private platforms so they
have the legal right to do whatever they
want what we're actually debating here
is I think something more important in
many ways what is the culture of free
speech what is the culture of free
expression what is the culture of
ownership does tolerating noxus and not
just annoying speech however you define
it of jerks ruin and things for everyone
or does excluding people easily and
often lead to more problems than it
solves the bloody events of just the
past few weeks suggest this is a topic
of vital relevance for how we think
about social media how we think about
political discourse and how we think
about the real world we've got two great
debaters tonight defending the
proposition so he is Thaddeus Russell
the author of a renegade history of the
United States he is right here and the
host of the unregistered podcast raised
by what he calls professional
revolutionaries and Berkeley in the
1960s and 70s that earned a PhD in
history from Columbia and has taught at
among other institutions Occidental
College here in Los Angeles he's the
founder of renegade University through
which
gives lectures and talks and has
seminars check out his site Thaddeus
Russell comm he's also kind enough at
various points to have credited reason
for helping him move beyond a kind of
conventional right-left ideological
divide that he grew up thinking was a
given opposing the proposition is
Kenneth white an attorney at the firm of
brown white and Osborn a formal federal
prosecutor to turn defense lawyer ken is
also the proprietor of the popular legal
blog Poquette who's subtitle is a group
complain about law liberty and leisure
check it out when you get a chance yes
it has an incredible Twitter feed as
well ken host the make no law podcast
available via the legal talk network and
he also appears regularly on kcrw
talking about is it all the Presidents
lawyers yes
so like that Ken also has a reason
connection when the federal government
subpoenaed reason and gagged reason for
asking for information about some of our
commenters Ken brought this act of
government bullying to the public by
writing a long brilliant piece about it
one of the actually I don't know for
sure but one of the apparently somebody
who got the complaint leaked it to Ken
and then he wrote a story and it took
off from there
here's how things will go tonight that
will speak first for about 15 minutes
Ken will respond with equal time we're
gonna have a five minute mutual rebuttal
period where the debaters savage each
other and ask each other questions and
pretend that they can stand being in the
same room with them I'm gonna ask a
couple questions then we're gonna open
up to audience Q&A for 20 or 30 minutes
they'll get five minutes to kind of
conclude their cases and then we will
vote and then we'll finish and you know
ransacking the taco truck outside so
without further ado take it away that
voting is now closed does that right Jim
okay so voting is closed but remember to
vote again as always vote early and vote
often so we didn't cover all the ground
rules so I just want to Nick if you
could clarify a few things for me that'd
be great
first of all can I curse okay
[Music]
so that's that's that's one question can
I curse am I allowed to curse the second
question is would you like for me to
curse so that's your culture of free
speech right there that's the one that
you chose and you can and we agree on
that let me ask you another question
about ground rules in here pretty this
is getting a little heavier that's not
me it's pretty crowded can I yell fire I
see two exits and I see about a hundred
people in front of me can I yell fire in
a crowded room according to the Supreme
Court right Oliver Wendell Holmes in the
very famous 1919 shank case said that
that's the thing that you can't do in
our society you can't yell fire in a
crowded room right why do you remember
this there's a great Harrison Ford movie
because it constitutes a clear and
present danger to the civilization
itself well that's a really reasonable
man isn't he Oliver Wendell Holmes that
sounds utterly reasonable it'd be very
dangerous for me to actually yell fire
and for you to believe it and start
rampaging and trying to run out the
doors and everybody would get stamp 'old
and it'd be terrible things happening do
you actually know what Oliver Wendell
Holmes was referring to what was the
fire do you know what that case was
about you know what it was about is a
man named Charles shank who spoke
Yiddish who was a socialist living in
New York City who was passing out flyers
urging young men not to enlist and to
dodge the draft during World War one
that's what that was about no one knows
that so Oliver Wendell Holmes in my
opinion not the greatest thinker in
American history certainly not somebody
who's really interested in Liberty why
on earth am I talking about this because
I'm having a debate with this guy about
free speech I'm having I'm telling you
this because it's become very clear to
me in studying the history of this that
it is actually always early
always has been a foreign policy
question
so as civil libertarians and I'm sure
this room is full of them right what are
the four worst times in American history
for civil libertarians when were civil
liberties in this country most severely
restricted by the government what
historians generally look at four times
when do you think those are I mean you
can have your own so they all have a
couple things in common you'll notice so
Civil War Abraham Lincoln
what suspends habeas corpus and arrests
thousands and thousands of people simply
and he said this for the crime of
disloyalty he said the time this is
necessary because secession is not it's
not bad because of slavery and racism
secession is bad because it threatens
American civilization we must preserve
the Union it was an existential threat
the south they believed that the South
would take over the north and bring
their slaves with them and destroy what
Abraham Lincoln and the Republicans
thought was American civilization World
War one basically the first amendment
went into the toilet
the Schenck case was one case of that
shank went to prison by the way for
advocating that young men not enlist in
the military that they dodged the draft
so Wendell Holmes was saying yeah he
should go to prison but other people
shouldn't world war two right Franklin
Roosevelt has effectively took control
of all of the major networks and told
them that they could only say certain
things favouring the war the New York
Times was a propaganda wing of the
federal of the federal government during
World War two then we have people who
often call the cold war as being a nadir
of civil liberties it was really the
crew
Riaan war it was during that time when
there was the fiercest restrictions of
civil liberties in this country so in
all four cases we have a war we really
have world wars in a sense and in all
four cases and this is really the nub of
it we had to enslave much of our
population in order to fight those Wars
now when you have to go that far where
you're enslaving your own population to
go fight and die in a place they'd never
been before you need to make it really
really high stakes so you can't allow
any loose ends
in those times so those are the moments
when the First Amendment went into the
toilet I think everybody agrees with
that those were the worst times in
American history is it just a
coincidence that in every case there was
a war and conscription necessary to
fight that war I don't think so
why still am I saying this now you may
have heard of this thing called Facebook
you may have heard that just last month
Facebook deleted permanently 35 accounts
some of which were major accounts with
millions of likes and followers does
anyone know how Facebook chose those
accounts Facebook in April was brought
before Congress you may remember this
Zuckerberg and company went up to
Capitol Hill and were grilled by the
Senators and basically weren't they
warned that if they don't start
censoring someone else might have to do
it for them okay now Mark Zuckerberg is
an engineering geek and he's about five
years old he knows nothing about
politics and so what he did was he said
hey oh my god the Russians apparently
have taken over our election in our
country they constitute a threat to
American civilization I've been told and
he said well I need I don't know
anything about this stuff because I'm
just a jackass from Harvard a coder who
do I who do i how do I know which sites
are actually Russian working for Putin
well I'll just ask the experts so he
entered into a contract with an
organization called the Atlantic Council
anyone know what the Atlantic Council is
oh yes they are they know what's best
for you they were founded they were
founded in 1961 by the RAND Corporation
from just down the road ran famous for
coming up with much of the tactics and
strategy carried out in the Vietnam War
things like pacification of villages
mass murder of civilians etcetera and
mass bombing carpet bombings
it was the organization's purpose was to
support promote and expand NATO always
has been people who sit on its board
today include Henry Kissinger Madeleine
Albright and every single person who's
made a major foreign policy decision of
the last 40 or 50 years I'm not kidding
you Facebook and Atlantic Council have a
partnership in which the Atlantic
Council tells Facebook which accounts
which pages are threats to national
security and those were the accounts
that were taken down by Facebook do you
think the people on the Atlantic Council
all of whom pretty much were former
members of the White House cabinets of
various presidents Democratic and
Republican do you think it's a there's a
chance that those people expect to be in
leadership positions in the future
sometime do you think that they might be
preparing the way for that right now do
you think that they would like to have
less criticism of their foreign policy
aims right now in the public sphere
because what they have said publicly is
they want NATO to be expanded all the
way around Russia they moved it all the
way to the borders of Russia but this is
public by the way so I'm not making this
up they've said no we need NATO to
expand to the south of Russia and then
go all the way and encircle both Russia
and China to make sure that they don't
do bad things anymore so free speech and
war have never been friendly to each
other right and they're always joined
and this is something that civil
libertarians and First Amendment people
often miss is that's the one carve out
has always been the one carve out you
are not allowed to advocate anything
that gets in the way of American foreign
policy in the world
especially if you are attempting to
discourage our boys from signing up to
go fight in Vietnam or Germany or
Alabama so that's what's at stake here
this is not just about what gets to be
said on college campuses this is a core
I'm sorry if I sound like a conspiracy
theorist it's a conspiracy it's a
conspiracy here's the great thing though
it's all open what I have told you I
learned from these these really radical
fringe organizations called Time
magazine Wired magazine Reuters this is
in the news it's right there apparently
no one cares to look it up okay that's
one reason I would like to encourage
social media platforms to allow free
speech that's not to me even the most
powerful argument against Ken's position
though the most obvious easiest way I
think to demolish that position from a
civil libertarian perspective is to
simply point out another fact Facebook
Twitter Google all of them have received
billions of B billions tens of billions
of dollars in direct subsidies and tax
breaks over the last five to ten years
billions and billions of dollars they've
also been given land on which to build
their new headquarters and all even
noticed there's a Twitter headquarters
and a Google headquarters and a Facebook
headquarters and apparently every pretty
much every city right in many of those
cases the land the property was given to
them by the local government so are
those are those still private entities
should they just be treated like you and
me in our living room they're taking our
tax dollars big time and then telling us
what we can and cannot say on their
social media platforms so what I am
calling for is two things I'm calling
for a culture of free speech generally
if you're a civil libertarian you need
to be calling for it all the time not
imposing on any of these
forms or entities on sort of this
[ __ ] egalitarian thing where you
have to allow free speech I don't want
to impose anything on the Catholic
Church they know what they stand for I
know what they stand for
they are totally honest about it there's
nothing secret we know who they are fine
do your thing I'm not imposing free
speech on you I don't want to do that
but if you're gonna claim to be a social
social media platform and you're taking
my tax money either you give me my money
back or you call yourself something else
that's it call yourself what you are
Twitter and Facebook which is we are
centrist globalist imperialists we
support the center of the Republican
Party and the center of the Democratic
Party and that's who we are
if you say things that are concordant
with that you can have a blast you can
say racist things you can say sexist
things on our website you can do
whatever you want if you differ from
that in any way by the way the 35 sites
that were taken down 35 pages they were
taking about down by Facebook guess what
they were some of them some of those
people are in this building right now
they were left-wing communist anti-war
people and they were right-wing
libertarian anti-war people all of whom
were questioning this narrative about
Russian have Russia having taken over
our country and constituting a threat to
our very existence so I want honesty I
want you to say Twitter and Facebook
what you actually will allow and won't
allow in terms of language and ideas and
if you do honestly believe that you are
running a social meaning including all
people media platform then yeah you
better have some free speech and we
should always be encouraging them in
those moments in those places to welcome
cursing and yelling fire especially
yelling fire because yelling fire now
you know really is about saying let's
not have World War three that's all
we're trying to do and they're not
letting us say that
and they're taking our tax money or
they're rigging the game so that they
win and they have these isn't amazing
how they have these monopolies Facebook
and Twitter these incredible Google
these incredible how did they get that
because San Francisco and California and
Oregon in Washington in Washington DC in
New York State have given them billions
and billions and billions of dollars in
tax breaks that I don't get I have a
business that's in tech that's in media
that's in education I don't get that
none of their competitors get that or
have gotten that they are wings of the
of the federal and state and local
governments they are acting as their
propaganda wings
that's that either give us our money
back or be truly what you say you are be
honest let's know what's going on here
and let's always be interested in speech
rather than advancing a particular
foreign policy agenda by the way I'm not
saying it's necessarily a bad foreign
policy agenda I would just like to be
able to talk about it in public but
they're not letting us this is dangerous
I've always worried about war I never in
my adult life until now and I'm older
than you think I am worried that the
First Amendment is truly in jeopardy
until now and I'm not a conspiracy
theory guy I'm always the one saying al
Qaeda definitely did it guys calm down
I'm not the one saying oh my god Trump
won oh jesus now Nazis now we're all
dead I'm the opposite of that guy this
is the first time in my whole life I've
been doing politics my entire life first
time I've been worried that the First
Amendment is truly in jeopardy
quickly 2027 seconds to other pieces for
you to be panicked about panicked about
why this is so urgent hmm polls taken by
the fire foundation for individual
rights and education correct
show that support among college students
for for sorry 50% half of all college
students currently believe that the
First Amendment should not protect hate
speech okay so some people say the
people that robbed you suave writes
about oh they're just kids don't worry
about it Robbie stop writing about the
ice to be one of those people by the way
he's be a little irritated and reason
and Robbie for writing so much about
those kids on college campuses no maybe
you're not writing enough because guess
what now we see it we see that language
in the United States Senate right that
was a full-on attack on all civil
liberties that hearing that set of
hearings so they're gonna be in
government big time and they have no
sympathy for the First Amendment it's an
entire generation apparently number one
number two and I'm done the ACLU is no
longer the ACLU do you know this it is
no longer a Civil Liberties Union they
now have basically announced that they
will no longer defend you if defender of
speech rights if you have the wrong
politics
the ACLU no longer exists in this
country for all intents and purposes
this is this is urgent and I urge you to
vote yes
[Music]
well let me start out by repeating our
proposition that like universities
social media platforms such as Twitter
Facebook and YouTube should only remove
speakers and participants who are making
true threats or inciting violence so let
me start by quoting my favorite
philosopher Hannibal Lecter quoting my
second favorite philosopher Marcus
Aurelius for each particular thing asked
what is it what is its nature what is a
social media network it's not a
university isn't as a lawyer I can tell
you that if you go onto Facebook or
Twitter hoping to learn the law you may
find yourself arrested or otherwise
inconvenienced as I nearly was earlier
this evening long story when we'll go
into it now doctors will tell you you
certainly should not take medical advice
you get on Facebook or YouTube or
Twitter these are places where people
speak freely and speaking freely often
means speaking foolishly and wrong what
is a social media network it is also not
the state is it it is not the government
a social media network is a function of
a business it's a thing to make money
for the Twitter's and Facebook's and
YouTube's and it is a form of speech to
quote someone who's not a philosopher so
long as I at so far as I know Mitt
Romney corporations are people my friend
and they are corporations and businesses
whether it's your brother-in-law's
one-person startup or the biggest
company in America also have speech
rights those rights include deciding
fairly broadly what business to be in
what to sell deciding how to market and
deciding how to run something like a
social media network and running
social media network the way they want
to run it is a speech act if you don't
believe me I'd like to tell you about
Club Penguin how many people remember
Club Penguin so
Club Penguin was a fun little online
half social media network half online
game for kids it was a very popular way
for many of them to communicate
there was the periodic fear that al
Qaeda was using it to recruit all the
normal online social media stuff it was
aimed at 12 year olds it had 12 and
below I should say it had very strict
rules no yelling obscenities no running
around waving digital dildos whatever
what-have-you because it had a vision
for what it warns be it wanted to be a
safe and happy place for little kids
that was their speech and the speech of
the people who went there the parents
who let their kids hang out on Club
Penguin was part of it too that was
their speech and their free free
association their decision that this is
the place I want to go just as you might
decide to come here tonight to hear a
debate rather than someplace else
debating someplace up something else
just so as you might decide which bar or
restaurant you go to based on the
atmosphere what we say when we say that
social media networks ought to act like
the state and only punish things that
are outside the First Amendment is that
social media networks ought to be
speaking the way we want them to ought
to be associating the way we want them
to we want to dictate the way they
operate so in effect we're no better
than the people who are dictating to
them you need to ban this speech you
need to ban that speech you shouldn't
allow hate speech you shouldn't allow
these types of threats you shouldn't
allow mobbing or bullying all of those
arguments are on a continuum they're all
about us say
how other people should associate and
speak the this is heresy in this
building the culture of free speech is
[ __ ] okay the culture of free speech
the culture of free speech is a way to
elevate the argument you shouldn't say
that you should say this it's to pretend
that when you're saying that you are a
free speech champion rather than a
censor the culture of free speech is
telling people how they should associate
or not associate how they should speak
or not speak who shouldn't allow in
their living room or not because after
all who you allow in your living room
and whose living room you go to is very
much a part of who you are it's a part
of your free association and your
expression the culture of free speech by
no stretch of the imagination should
require you to say well I really don't
want to but to be Pro free speech I need
to let ken white coming into my living
room every night and rant for a few
hours about how terrible
fourth edition Dungeons & Dragons was
it's creepy it's weird I'm really not
interested I think he's a little harsh
on it actually it had some really
innovative ideas but I mean it's a
culture of free speech of course you
wouldn't say that because you recognize
that how you order your lives as part of
how you identify yourself it's part of
who you are and it's part of your
expression it's the same with Twitter or
Facebook or YouTube the companies are
deciding how to brand themselves that
are deciding how to sell themselves now
is it mercenary obviously it is but how
much human speech isn't mercenary on
some level or another
McDonald's is mercenary and how they
market themselves and how they portray
themselves every business is the market
that we talk about the marketplace of
ideas that we trust to order things
rather than having the government order
operates on an individual level what I
mean is that we don't say you have to
let me into your living room to rant
because of the marketplace of ideas we
say that if people find my ranting
entertaining then they'll let me in to
their living room part of the
marketplace of ideas is that businesses
like Twitter and Facebook and YouTube
well in the long term in the long run
rise and fall with whether or not their
users feel that they're giving them an
experience that they want whether or not
they feel that they are being unfairly
suppressed whether some point of view is
being suppressed and it's unacceptable
whether I can't say what I want I can't
meet the people I want or not and if you
buy into the idea that you will never
overturn the Twitter or Facebook
juggernaut I have some words for you
Geocities myspace Yahoo we are in this
age where we have 10 or 12 news cycles a
day so we think in very short term and
it's impossible to think of something
like Twitter or Facebook not being the
dominant social media entity but time
passes and things changed
no one says the marketplace of ideas is
going to be instant no one says that
you're going to build the social media
network that works the way you want it
to overnight but it won't take time to
persuade people to get other people to
come with you to patronize that business
that does things the way you want if you
like fried chicken and all you have in
town is McDonald's you're gonna be
disappointed for a while but sooner or
later you'll get a KFC so the
marketplace of ideas says that you've
got to work and gather people together
and persuade people not to do the same
thing not to only talk or debate or
associate the way you want to but enough
together to fall
a critical mass so that you have a
platform so you have other people who
will like you have maybe gab is your
thing or maybe Twitter is your thing
maybe you like that it's a little harder
there for them for people to attack you
with racial slurs you will get the
platform that you want eventually that's
the idea of the marketplace of ideas not
that we will put social pressure on
every platform to be the same to have
debate the same to approach life the
same the other reason it's important to
know that we're dealing not with the
government or universities but with
private businesses is that understanding
the way speech works is crucial to
protecting it I join a hundred percent
the concern that many college students
don't seem to understand free speech
appreciate it or support it but here's
the thing a crucial part of supporting
an understanding free speech is being
able to separate the public from the
private to separate the obligations of
the different components of our society
some of the same the same studies that
recently found that 50 percent or
something of students said hate speech
should be illegal also found that a very
large percentage of students said that
if a if a university brings a
controversial speaker then the law
should require that they give another
speaker with the opposite side the same
amount of time that's a fundamental
misunderstanding of the role of that
institution right it's kind of a
harkening back to the old fairness
doctrine that we've been done with for
many decades it's crucial for people to
understand the difference between the
public realm and the private realm and
the different rules that apply and I
think we confuse them when we start to
try to impose public realm norms public
realm laws things like true threats or
inciting violence as the touchstones
to our private sector businesses that
are expressions of our freedom of
expression the other fact is frankly
there's no way that these organizations
can do it right we all know that the the
moderation on Twitter on Facebook on
YouTube is a train wreck telling them
okay you can now we'd like you as a
social norm to let everyone on but you
can keep out true threats and incitement
you know how that's gonna go
I mean last week Twitter was letting
threats from a guy who was sending mail
bombs to people across the country
because it didn't detect that that was a
threat while at the same time banning
people who are saying very innocuous
things moderation on social media is
always always going to be a disaster
because it's never gonna be profitable
for it to be good it's always gonna be
done by bad a eyes or disaffected
workers and it's going to be terrible so
a vision where it hues to some sort of
principled First Amendment idea as an
example is always going to be a pipe
dream it's always going to be in effect
no moderation or random moderation and
it's not reasonable to expect much more
than that there's another reason though
I think and that has to do with support
for the very concept of free speech as
that suggested the support is not as
strong as it could be and maybe it never
has been we like to believe in this idea
that there was a golden age when
everyone supported First Amendment
values and I've looked at a lot in First
Amendment cases and a lot of First
Amendment history I'm not sure when that
was based on American history I think
that public support for the right to say
unpopular things has always been tenuous
the bargain that we offer to people is
that when someone says hateful things
when they shout racial slurs at you or
your spouse or your kids
that we're not going to jail them we're
not going to allow you to sue them but
we believe in more speech and we believe
in freedom of association so you can
stop going to that place you cannot
associate with those people you can talk
back to those people that's the bargain
but if we start to tell people okay not
only do you have to allow these people
to shout obscene epithets at you and you
know say what they're gonna do to your
kids and use racial slurs at you all
these things that have happened to me on
Twitter regarding my kids not only are
they not going to go to jail not only is
no one gonna be able to sue them but you
know what we've decided the social norm
is they just get to do that here they're
not gonna be moderated they're not gonna
be kicked off suck it up and no no
reputable social media network is gonna
do that good social media networks let
that happen
we're not goin Courage you as a free
speech value to go find a different
living room to go find the social media
network that has the atmosphere that you
like the one that you choose to choose
to subject yourself to that sort of
speech or not to associate with people
like that
or not no we're going to have as a
social norm not only do you not punish
it you gotta just sit there and take are
people going to take that bargain what's
the impact of that on the support for
the more fundamental norms the legal
norms of free speech if we start trying
to sell people on the concept that well
sorry if you like Facebook you have to
like people shouting racial slurs at
your kids that's just the way it is do
they start to rethink a little bit their
support of free speech is an entire norm
if they think this is kind of [ __ ]
because why don't I have free speech why
don't I get to choose a platform that's
the way I like it why don't I get to
associate
with who I want I think the bargain is
essential the bargain is we allow
terrible things we allow arable
offensive speech we don't let the
government punish it but we have to
allow just as broad responses and the
broad response might be to be
unreasonably standoffish to be
unreasonably censorious in your personal
voluntary interactions to associate
yourself in a way that other people
might not agree with to be too broad and
the people you think are offensive and
avoid them because there is no rational
theory of free speech I submit that says
you shouldn't judge the Nazi shouters
but you should judge the people who
don't want to hang out with them thank
you thank you all right so now we're
gonna have a couple of minutes of
back-and-forth here and I'm gonna take
the moderators prerogative before they
you guys give your rebuttals just ask
quick question then we'll go to you guys
sad should Jewish mingle allow Catholics
first of all am I still allowed to curse
yes okay you're and now you're actually
forced this is the contractual
obligation no no I thought I made that
clear didn't I that I want I want people
who don't take my money to do what they
want okay in terms of their own internal
rules and in fact I want I encourage
that because Ken's point is actually a
very important point I think it may have
been missed too that I learned this from
him okay that imposing a culture of free
speech aren't universally is is
something I really don't like it's
called imperialism right so I'm
completely with you on that and I don't
we don't disagree on that back to you
here one of the questions you one of the
things you were arguing about is that
Twitter Facebook and many companies that
get tax breaks or incentives should show
up at a certain place they stop
being a private entity and there's
something different going on it's a
Catholic Church which you said you don't
want to tell Catholics what to do the
Catholic Church is the biggest tax break
operator ever sorry I'm so why wouldn't
you imposing that the Catholic Church
offer sacraments from Nick I was wrong I
take it back
the Catholic Church that imposed should
have pure first amendment rules
throughout no we should stop giving them
our money right I mean it's like it's
the same it's similar to the immigration
debate right side here about
libertarians it's like oh we can't let
the immigrants in because of the social
welfare stand like why don't you just
let the immigrants in and not let them
take the social welfare or maybe attack
the social welfare state instead right
because if you're for liberty you let
people cross borders right okay sorry I
mean I don't even know if anybody in
here has that position but I've heard it
among a lot of libertarians so it's very
similar right we're barking up the wrong
tree or something I think often but yeah
so I get back to you well let me now
finish the thought what is what's the
one question you want us I mean I love
you Ken and you're a hero but I think
you missed you lighted that I don't know
I mean you lighted that major point I
was making about what do we do and it's
a tough question I'm not saying it's
easy because the Catholic Church is a
great great example they take huge
amounts of tax breaks etc what do we do
with that
what do we do with these corporations
that take not a small amount
I'm talking about billions and billions
and billions to look it up Facebook
Twitter all of them what do we do when
the government here it is guys when the
government grants essentially a natural
monopoly to the people they like
politically you understand that's
exactly what's at that Slayer now this
is not some wacky fringe theory here
this is very very clear now that that's
what they're doing what do you do when
the government gives all these subsidies
and land and buildings to these to these
corporations for political reasons to
put forward a particular political point
of view are those still just private
entities like your living room you're
solving the wrong problem
so if
are going after the problem that we're
subsidizing too much there's too much
government and private entanglement the
way to solve the problem Pro Liberty is
not to therefore make all these private
entities act more like the government
it's to reduce the subsidies and the
government backing and that type of
thing maybe it's to enforce antitrust
law more maybe it's to really challenge
the tax breaks which are all the time
completely ludicrous and you know social
media start talking about sports tax
breaks III don't think though that we
increase Liberty or free speech by
letting the government by subsidizing
control more of the way that private
enterprises and private people are I
think I just happened upon a brilliant
libertarian strategy going forward right
every time we come across one of these
entities say hey do you take my money
you do okay so here's the deal now your
public you do what I say or you can give
me my money back
Catholic Church Facebook whoever it is I
mean I think in other words I'm not this
is not a practical program I'm putting
forward here you know descent the great
senators in Washington DC are not going
to take this up anytime soon I'm talking
about a cultural movement which is what
we all are about here's what reason is
about that's what I'm about to you're
about I think we should start calling we
know not should I think we need to or
they're literally going to kill us
I mean I'm that's I'm not kidding you I
think they are driving us to world war
three with Russia which is already going
on by the way that's what it's about
that's why it's so important for them to
control Facebook they are deadly serious
about it Facebook is this year the
number one funder of the Atlantic
Council I can let me ask you a question
what you know you take a sometimes we
make these distinctions between a
platform and a channel so Twitter
YouTube Facebook these are platforms we
don't call them as specific channels
what about something like the daily
Sturmer
or stormer you know like at neo-nazi
what
website should they what if they cannot
connect to the website what if they
cannot register through any company that
allow you know that does registry for
the Internet is that a problem I think
it is a problem and the question is how
we address why is the internet then
different than Twitter or YouTube or
Facebook well I think you're talking
about Internet backbone type functions
so hosting I think is more in the middle
it's not quite so much crucially
backbone but if you're talking about
like you know domain name type stuff
where really the that controls the
entire internet that tells things where
to go you can tell I'm not technical in
the way I'm describing this there's a
real difference I think there's a
spectrum between my blog on the one side
and the companies that you know drive
we're all internet traffic goes on the
other I think that the common carrier
arguments that you hear that some entity
should be regulated like the phone
company or the electric company or
something like that are probably
strongest for things that are completely
non communicative like you know or the
the address of the address of a neo not
maybe site maybe are even a neo-nazi say
right say you know what their actual
Nazis there's nothing new about it but a
Nazi site right sure so I think there's
a better argument for treating as a
common carrier and regulating the way
you would the phone company or our
trains or things like that when you're
talking about the genuine the equivalent
of phone lines right but I think the
closer you get to entities that have a
message that have speech and that's
anywhere very much so on my blog maybe a
little less arguably on Twitter to some
extent something like Bluehost or
DreamHost or one of these branded themed
hosts then I think the further you get
down that way the more they have a First
Amendment right themselves to decide who
to associate with what I want to ask
people to do if you want to ask a
question we have a microphone set up in
the back if you could perform a
and you will our tech people will help
there so you can either come in from the
cold or stand up and go is sitting long
or a stand in line and ken do you have a
question for that or a point of a
rejoinder
sure dad let me ask you this
do you think all speech is equally
speech encouraging so what i'm what i
mean is this do you think that the sort
of speech that some platforms like
Twitter and Facebook are banning
encourages speech or is is part of the
culture of free speech to promote
discourse okay so does the culture of
free speech include yelling racial slurs
at someone on Twitter does that
encourage speech does yelling racial
slurs encourage speech yeah Oh obviously
yes I mean because we've had just an
absolute volcano of speech in the last
two years haven't way whenever --nt and
when anyone says anything even slightly
racially insensitive what happens we get
a torrent of speech in response doing
well does it encourage the speech of the
person who's being yelled at it depends
on the person and as people are lining
up what do you guys make of the the fact
to though that I mean has your
experience ever been marred by stupid
people on Twitter in this sense I mean
your others myself testimony Nick
Gillespie by the way I think it was
yesterday tweeted wouldn't life be
better without Twitter yes so just just
just for the record just say you know no
but what I'm saying is it's very easy to
block people and to mute people and to
ignore I I never encountered an Alex
Jones video on YouTube unless I went out
and sought it out it's so why are we
getting so hot and bothered about all of
this ugly speech when it's like one
button to get rid of it forever I'm not
sure it is one
but yes there have been occasions when
they're having enough swarms of people
coming at me when I've annoyed white
nationalists groups like that where it
is genuinely degrade the experience and
I've taken a break you know after they
talked about used racial slurs for my
daughters and said how they were gonna
rape them then yes that impairs my
experience and we're still talking about
Club Penguin this time that was Twitter
and so yes I can block them one by one
it takes a long time right but the way I
see it
part of my freedom of association and my
choice as a consumer is finding a
platform that has a moderation scheme
that I can live with and one Twitter I
mean they they blocked me for stupid
reasons they blocked people for stupid
reasons but out of a ton of terrible
ones maybe they're the best so I think
that I like my freedom to choose
platforms that have a particular
moderating style that I like okay let's
let's ask a question please and make
sure it is a question at least you know
have intonation rising at the end and if
you would give your name as well I'm
Darren
Anna thanks for having this thing
tonight this is great my first time here
I'm generally a pretty big FreeMarkets
guy anti-regulation guy but I feel like
in this day and age the biggest threat
to the free market is our monopolies and
it seems that's why we're had and you
know Disney swallowing up every film
studio you know these social networks I
feel like yeah my gut instinct says let
you know let them do what they want
they're private companies but like I
really I'm sorry your name but not not
Ken man my name is Ken you're not again
what is your what's the question I just
saw it seems that you even brought up
Ken brought up gab you can go to gab gab
was shut down just this weekend for
having you know non
non-conforming believes in because
possibly it was too far right so I'm
just wondering what do you guys think
like it seems to me that these other
companies Facebook and Twitter Instagram
it's not so easy to make up your own
company more it's because there's so
much money and the other thing so what
how do you how do you think do you
really think I guess do you really think
it's that easy to make up a new company
to fight that these days no so so gab
and mines guess what they don't get they
don't get tax breaks they don't get free
land they don't get anything from the
government so yeah again I'm sorry but
please after this just Google just
Google Facebook to pick your company and
subsidies and you'll see I'm talking
tens of billions of dollars of tax
breaks they don't in the city of San
Francisco Facebook pays zero dollars in
payroll tax I would like to have that as
a business owner thank you very much
competing with them I am competing with
them right gab is competing with them
mines is competing with them they don't
get those tax breaks they don't get to
have a fancy office in downtown San
Francisco for basically free right
Twitter opened their headquarters in
downtown San Francisco three years ago
same deal huge tax breaks no payroll tax
right so it's completely rigged you know
so like if you're gonna take my money
rig the game so that I can't enter a
market and then tell me what meat what I
can't can and can't say in there
monopolies that were created by the
government right that's the issue okay
so I would say again we're solving the
wrong problem the right way to solve
that problem is by looking more at
antitrust law whether they are actually
monopolies to go vigorously after all
those subsidies and question why people
are getting them but I don't think it's
to turn them into something that is
government like I don't think that that
promotes Liberty I also think you have
to ask when you say it's not easy to
just go out there and start your own
company you have to ask compared to what
at what point in human history has it
been easier for someone disfavored by
the government unpopular with unpopular
views to reach more people has there
ever been a time when it's been
for that to happen that's exactly why
what's happening is happening because
they understand this this is the freest
moment and they're making sure it will
no longer be this free okay next
question my name is Thomas I just was
wondering about you're talking about
MySpace do you think that's a I think
that's a poor comparison because they
didn't have political power at the time
that tech was in its infancy how are
they going to convince a city to give
them that much subsidy and on top of
that you have intellectual property
rights which is another sort of Damocles
that they can hold over their
competitors heads where they can say hey
you infringed on my idea what is we need
what's the question so my question is
isn't that another layer of collusion
with the government to keep out
competitors in terms of intellectual
property where they can say hey you
infringe slightly on my idea I can
launch a lawsuit and now you don't have
the financial means to then defend
yourself against this so essentially
that just puts you out of businesses
what we want to address that or the idea
of a large corporation having legal
weapons at its disposal or is it really
it's really about IP right yeah you want
it no I don't I mean yes IP obviously
restricts trade right I mean it's it's
obviously you're handing a monopoly to
an entity right a business entity it's
the same deal I mean let me elaborate
really quickly on this I meant to
mention also another fairly important
entity or institution in our society
that's gotten even bigger subsidies than
Facebook and Twitter have and Google huh
which is the higher education system
okay so right when Abraham Lincoln was
throwing people in prison for being
disloyal at that very moment the federal
government was hand giving free land to
missionaries Christian missionaries who
wanted to start colleges and now we we
completely fund all the colleges and
universities in this country except for
about 2 to the gills with the federal
student loan program if we if we took
away all the federal subsidies and state
and local subsidies for higher education
there would be about four colleges left
in this country and I can't wait for
that day by the way
but I also it's the same question right
so my son if he goes to college you will
be going soon I will be I will be if he
goes but he years ago avianna that's
that's another debate you know so I mean
the position of paying lot quite a bit
in taxes right for these colleges and
universities to support the federal
student loan program which by the way do
you know that it makes a profit for the
federal government it's a profitable and
we still pay taxes to support it Matt
Taibbi wrote a great article in Rolling
Stone about this I highly recommend it
so I'm paying all this money for these
places where they tell my son you can't
say certain things I'd like my first
amendment back or I'd like my money back
do you agree then that if you get a
dollar through a student loan which goes
to the student that then goes to a
particular University that university
whether it's private or not should have
to abide by the same rules of speech as
a public university I'm sort of thinking
through this I think it's a great
question but yeah basically I think at
least they have to answer to that don't
they don't they I mean come on guy I
mean yeah yeah I think that quote did go
back to the question the the reference
to myspace or any of the others are not
to suggest they were exactly the same of
course they're not
times have changed or the last 10-15
years the idea is that I don't think we
can assume that something it seems like
juggernaut now it's still gonna be one
in the next 10 or 15 years politics
changes dramatically tech changes
dramatically and I think that when
you're thinking about having a name of
starting new things to challenge the
current juggernauts you have to take a
longer view and so even if Twitter or
Google seem unstoppable now I'm not sure
that's going to be the case in 15 years
and actually there is evidence that
Twitter and Facebook at least in North
America cards are starting to see
declines and average daily users or the
duration wait guys be a sign that they
are not that competitive or that they've
become cesspools okay but let's go to
the next question hi my name is Tommy
everybody's had almost the same
questions I have but I will go a little
bit further on a couple of these things
for Thad you you have this idea your
public now do what I say the eye is
always going to be the government though
because they're the ones that are making
the rules my preference is always to get
my money back by the way just so I'm
clear right
right that's our preference is always
you get to say whatever you want in your
church or your school or your social
media whatever platform but give me my
money back
yeah I I do think the subsidies point
demolishes the idea or at least puts a
big dent in the idea that we don't know
what's gonna be there in 15 years
because it's a huge advantage for Ken
would the government prosecute and even
recognize a monopoly that's created by
the government because of the subsidies
only if we demand it only if people
require it
so antitrust prosecutions have gone all
over the place
I mean look right now the subject of
going after Twitter or Google or
Facebook on antitrust grounds is popular
in some circles for political reasons
from the right because they are
perceived as on the left and indeed I
think a lot of the talk about how these
social networks are improperly
restricting speech is politically driven
so that has views that they are
assisting one spectrum and you know
pro-war that type of thing I think the
way it's being spun now at least in
Congress is very much a right versus
left the notion that to fight against
the Liberals and all these people we
have to take these back for real
Americans who you know don't don't live
on this coast or the other coast but
live in the middle so but to go back to
your question antitrust prosecutions
have come and gone with the political
winds they can change again and if you
make it enough of an issue as some
people are trying to do on this specific
issue then yes you could have more I
just might say one thing about so
another
warning flag if I haven't scared you
enough tonight the the response by the
few people on the Left who are
interested in this who are just as
outraged for the same reasons that I am
unfortunately there their answer is what
do you think make make social media
public utilities which is a great way of
course to open up speech and you know
expand the Overton Window and everybody
can sit right it's exactly the worst
possible idea more government control
but so be warned that that's coming down
the pike too so and in antitrust real
quickly and I really am done being a
historian again the great great great
Marxist historian Gabriel Kolko showed
pretty definitively that antitrust was a
scam always and that without regulation
by the government some Marx is talking
ok
competition flourished and it was
actually intervention by the government
for in antitrust cases at the turn of
the 20th century that caused the
consolidation of capital so it is far
from clear that antitrust will get us
anything we want and think about the
people who will be wielding those
lawsuits that's the thing right
did you watch I mean have you watched
you know who the Senators and stuff are
recently right I mean that's who would
be doing this do you think do you think
Cory Booker and Camilla Harris and that
jackass from Alabama really are just
gonna like be neutral and let us have
our free speech and they're not gonna
use it for political purposes give me a
break
let's go to the next question hi
everyone I'm Jack and so this question I
guess is primarily for Thad but so in
the case of say someone like Alex Jones
who sort of who blatantly and openly
disseminates false information and
harassed like encourages harassment
against multiple groups of people what
obligation do social media companies
have to I don't know like do they have
an obligation to keep that to keep that
sort of speech in the interest of free
speech or is there a line that can be
drawn at all in terms of what like
social media companies they need to kill
Alex Jones clearly because he
constitutes a threat because his words
her
so there's another thing we need to talk
about right
why on earth why on earth does even does
hate speech hurt anyone why does it need
to hurt anyone
must we be hurt by other people's words
I submit to you know we don't have to I
submit to you even if I were a Sandy
Hook parent I wouldn't need to be upset
by what the stupidest person in public
life says about my child's death right
Alex Jones last time I saw him was
yelling literally at a pile of [ __ ] in
Texas okay that's all I know about the
guy I mean literally literally you've
seen the video yeah okay so Mira was
available so I whatever Alex Jones says
about me or my son or anything like it's
just hilarious to me and you don't and I
think so for I was gonna say for about a
year and a half now I've had about 1.5
million men screaming at me because I
said that I don't believe in truth on a
podcast once okay it's every single day
they call me [ __ ] they call me [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuck cuck cuck [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] fat
Kaka twenty thirty fifty hundred times a
day for a year and a half okay I know
what it's like it's like these people
are gnats to me it's annoying when
there's a thousand gnats around you but
a Matt isn't that right and we need to
interrogate this thing about why we're
necessarily hurt by certain words said
by people can I ask what about something
like daxing or if people were sending
stuff to your address if they were
telling people publicly where you live
well then I kill them but that's how
that works yeah so you know and it kind
of mean that like I mean I think
personal it's that's a matter of
personal safety right and I'm kind of
for privatizing personal safety and
security frankly aren't we kinda in this
room a little bit yeah
so if you docks me good luck with that
good luck with that okay I'm just gonna
hand you my card now in case
he is a defense lawyer so how about the
respond to that question
thank you Ken I will be needing it soon
my answer use I think that my opinion is
that social media has a moral obligation
there but not a legal one as long as
they're keeping within the bounds of the
First Amendment and section 230 which is
the one that generally makes them
invulnerable to lawsuits for the content
of stuff like that that said I want a
system where I make moral choices about
which social media I use based on how
they make moral choices
I want a system where I choose or don't
choose Facebook or Twitter or anything
else based on them doing that just like
everyone else
and our collective moral choices make
different approaches rise or fall and I
have to argue a little bit with that on
this whole thing about why do words hurt
us hell I don't know but to me the idea
why do you let words hurt you is no more
of an apt question why do you feel you
have to use those words I leave that up
to people I decide I don't let the
government regulate it go through
criminal law or through defamation law
or things like that when it's words like
that but I don't want to tell people how
they should feel about words and I
generally don't want to tell them what
words to you so I don't think we should
order society that I'm clearly right I
did not say how you should feel I'm just
saying you don't necessarily need to
feel particular things about particular
things that's all that's next question
my question is a slight extension of
your debate question but I think there
are a lot of similar arguments on both
sides should PayPal and companies like
that stop processing payments for
websites that host hate speech and all
kinds of bad speech or should they have
a neutral policy who wants to take that
first sure I mean
this is a question to me that's you know
is PayPal what is it like what is it is
it more like a bank do we let banks
choose who to do business with or not do
business with this is actually a live
question some banks are deciding not to
do business with gun manufacturers or
the NRA because of their political
beliefs so do we want to start
regulating that I don't think so do we
want to have a social norm that banks or
PayPal or any of those don't make
decisions based on politics again rather
than a broad social norm I like us
voting with our feet and saying if
PayPal
pisses me off because they start
processing something I like then I stop
using them and I encourage others to
stop using them but I don't think that
you can have a universal broad social
norm that entities like that should
never decide to stand up for what they
believe in yeah I mean I think it's just
an extent well you sort of said it's an
extension of the question but it's also
an extension of the answer I think right
so yeah I think I mean I kind of want to
know what where PayPal's offices are in
San Francisco and exactly you know how
they know I'm sure that they've got more
than their I'm sure they've very very
friendly with the Board of Supervisors
up there yes so yeah great next question
hi there my name is Erin hi how are you
so I'm wondering I had another question
and I heard an answer a minute ago that
no I had to quickly change the question
because anyway so I'm wondering what
what actions do you think individuals
can take to move closer toward a culture
of communication and listening and as
opposed to censorship whether it's
self-censorship or censorship of others
what actions could we take to move
closer toward that and for example could
some of those actions be
to proactively ask and engage in
conversation with people of different
views great question yeah
and it's something I it's something I
deal with once a week you know what I
mean
so not once a week but many weeks on my
show on my podcast you know I have I've
had many many people whose politics are
radically different than mine and what I
what I try to do I don't know how
successful I am always but I my
intention is to model the behavior I
would like to see others take right
which is to simply be open to the ideas
but here's the important thing here's
the important thing that liberals don't
do and civil libertarians often don't do
challenge them be comfortable in
conflict be comfortable with
intellectual and political conflict and
that's where Americans are just babies
we're just tiny little babies when we
have the littlest conflict we start
screaming and crying and freaking out
and we got a runaway right that's
Twitter that's that's political
discourse in this country so what I try
to model is that you know it's like no I
I think what you just said actually is
racist but let's talk about it right or
huh that sounds an awful lot like
fascism what you're advocating orgy do
you really want to nationalize the
television industry you know talk about
it have the conflict state exactly where
I stand on this but hear it out hear it
out see here's the thing be curious
about your enemies be curious about your
enemies okay that is 100 percent right I
couldn't say any better I think what
we're lacking a lot is the combination
of worthwhile discourse that's not just
screaming obscenities each other but
really genuinely challenging the ideas
on the other side and I interact with a
lot of people I strongly disagree with
on issues and I think I learned the most
and get the most out of it when I have
that kind of discussion when I when we
genuinely argue about but you know in a
friendly civil way up to a point about
the points that we're making it's
actually it's actually patronizing I
think and disrespectful to not
challenged people okay so I've been in
college campuses for my entire adult
life and this is ask a black person
who's been a student or a faculty member
on a college campus I'll bet you
anything they will tell you they get
patronized all the damn time because
that's what goes on right if they say
something that the rest of the faculty
disagrees with they don't get any
pushback I've seen this happen a
thousand times a black person gets up I
know that there's disagreement and no
one contradicts them because they're
scared to do that right that ends up
treating the black person like a child
it makes puts us in the position of
being their parents or taking care of
them we're worried that they're gonna be
hurt their feelings are gonna be hurt so
we take upon ourselves to protect the
poor vulnerable black person right and
that's the way I think political
discourse generally operates it's the
baby and the adult so the baby starts
screaming and crying and oh and half the
adults want to take care of the baby and
half the adults want to keep yelling at
the baby right that's what I saw you
just want to point out I think you just
figured black people as babies and
that's kind of racist
wait no I'm stunned I think that's how
they are treated yes the last we have
time for one last question really really
quick now cannot I'm sorry
no you cannot thank you this is our
platform but thank you okay final just
yell fire everyone will leave can you
hear me I should get so my question for
you and that they're gonna decide what
where hate speech ends and then it might
end up including all conservative speech
and all libertarian speech and that
that's kind of dangerous and there are a
lot of impressionable minds on Facebook
and that's kind of scary surely am i
because people are idiots so but that
would be their speech that would be
their freedom of association and the
whole point is that we don't regulate
people's speech and freedom of
association when we have this model
where we vote with our feet where we go
to different platforms that are run the
way we like that have the type of
atmosphere we like that have the
moderation style
we like some of them we're gonna be
absolutely terrible sometime gonna be
terrible in the other direction they're
gonna allow you know there's a whole lot
of very scary stuff that comes short of
true threats inciting violence some of
them are going to be I think some people
call them you know Care Bear world's
where only the most completely
inoffensive safe speech is permitted but
the marketplace of ideas is always going
to have bad results and cesspools of
various types and I think the way you
deal with that is not by creating this
norm where everyone should deal with
speech the same way everyone should
moderate the same way but you know let
the thousand flowers bloom and let's
choose the platforms that have the
moderation approaches that meets our
individual needs okay
we are going to go to our final summary
statements and sad
would you like to you have the podium
for five minutes to sum up your your
ideas Wow totally unprepared
I want your questions I want your
comments I don't know what do you think
did I do it
did it win like what I mean no I think I
think I gave you everything I got here I
mean do you want to hear more about
subsidies that's sexy
you want taller amounts I don't have
them during the billions I can tell you
that yeah it's a Congress I guess what
I'm saying is here that I am trying to
introduce a new conversation okay I
don't have I don't have all the precise
answers I have a lot of answers for
myself right about my money and my
rights and all that stuff I don't know
if you're an other the answers for you
but I do think we have to start asking
different questions and thinking about
this differently and having a different
conversation
so I interviewed nadine strossen two
great great civil libertarian hero
nadine strossen former president of the
aclu as good as it gets on this right
she did not know she did not know the
direct connection between wartime
conscription and restrictions on speech
by the Supreme Court she didn't she
wasn't aware of that history and then I
started looking into it
found out that a lot of very famous
civil libertarians like her are simply
unaware of that very important thing
that that's the one thing the government
will not allow us to say that is always
been the only thing Yeats 1959 seven
Yeats decision fifty-eight right okay
I bracketed it the Yeats decision left
the clearance is clear and present
danger doctrine in there they didn't
touch that part you can't say when we go
to the neck when we're at war with
Russia and they're calling for a draft
because they need that many troops on
the ground to take over all that
territory it's a lot of territory in
Asia right we will never be able to say
you can't take my son
they've never allowed us to say you
can't take my son that's the fire that's
the fire I don't know I'm pretty you
know it means a lot to me
right my son seventeen right going to
college and he could be going to
somewhere else pretty soon so this is
urgent for me and I want to have a
different conversation I got nothing
else for you just vote for it I'm gonna
push back on what they are ever going to
allow we are in terms of the law it just
about the best place the first
amendments ever been the last couple of
decades in First Amendment law have been
more free speech protective on the law
and what the government can do than any
other time in the First Amendment's
history time and time again the Supreme
Court has pushed back against the idea
that the government can regulate things
because they're offensive even very
offensive that the government can set
the terms for what categories are are
aren't protected in every way the
government has steadily attempted to
censor more and the Supreme Court has
pushed back you even heard a lot of
complaints from the left that I think
the term is weaponizing for
speech that now this is straying into
areas of the economy and that's not
right we only wanted to do it for you
know the stuff we wanted to talk about
so I don't share right now the concern
that the law is going to get more
censorious because the trends in the
other direction and there none of the
signs and those decisions suggesting
that it's slowing down or going the
other way I mean when the Supreme Court
says 8 to 1 that you can stand outside a
military funeral and say God loves dead
Marines and things like that then I
think we're getting pretty far along the
way what we do have though is a
continuing debate and disagreement about
what I called [ __ ] the culture of
free speech how do we want to deal with
each other how do we want to interact
with each other what's right and what's
wrong and how should we regulate it
socially and what I'm trying to say is
this that the best way is always going
to be that marketplace of ideas and
voting with your feet and deciding not
to shut down that person you can't stand
but maybe not go out with your friends
when they're part of the group I think
that we have to take a second look like
dad says at what we think of speech or
isn't what we think expression is or
isn't you might notice that there's this
trend towards saying all these people
are you know against free speech when
they do things that are very much free
speech you get that with the
government's and states trying to pass
laws making it legal to run over people
who are blocking the roads during
protests you see it in a spate of laws
that are getting struck down with state
government saying that you can be kicked
out of school
if you hackle a speaker these are things
that are trying to
reclassify dissent against dissent
dissent within the discussion as being
illegitimate
and there is a philosophical attempt
there to to say that when you say you
know you're a racist [ __ ] that
somehow that is on a different speech
level than being the racist [ __ ] I
don't think that it is I think that our
decision to speak out with more speech
to call people out for things we think
are terrible to decide not to associate
with them that that is just as core to
free speech as what they are saying in
the first place
it's what I call the first speaker
problem this idea that we're only
concerned with the first person who
starts speaking and whether or not the
reaction will deter or chill that person
well what about the second speaker what
about the person who reacts sometimes
these social media networks are that
second speaker they are making decisions
both I think mercenary and heartfelt
about what kind of society societies
they want to be running and making money
off of and I think that that speech that
Association act is just as legitimate as
the ones the people who want to speak on
them thank you give a big extra round of
applause for both Pat and Ken and I want
everybody now to go back to Soho
vote.com
to do the post debate vote and then what
we're going to have some uncomfortable
moments of impromptu patter while we
calculate but so the proposition is like
universities social media platforms such
as Twitter Facebook and YouTube should
only remove speakers and participants
who are making truth threats or inciting
violence you can make your your final
vote
I forgotten what I voted at this point
yeah okay so and while we do that Ken
you were almost arrested today what what
laws did you break it's on and I
discovered that when the police pulled
me over and so do cops go after lawyers
with special they do and that's why you
genuinely do not want to tell them your
lawyer so I I did the things that I've
been trained to do which is put my hands
on the wheel ask for permission to reach
from my wallet
do all the things that cops have told me
make them feel warm and fuzzy and safe
and at the end of the encounter since I
had acted deferentially to them they let
me off with a ticket and didn't tell my
car I've been in handcuffs three times
now I said a rep I thought that was just
between the two of us but anyway it's
okay man it's okay it's okay I'm a
little bit of a leather boy you know
anyway so that just went what was the
question the last time well I've never
oh yeah I was a red oh okay it was
arrested I was put in handcuffs seven
years ago but I was arrested in 1991
guess why go for for running on to the
Bay Bridge to block it to protest the
Gulf War is stupid but you know I cut
myself a little slack because the cause
was just but yeah that was the last time
it was not in San Francisco though not
too popular there yeah we'd call it we
caused a lot of trouble so now we are
getting the final results to the
proposition again the proposition was
like University social media platforms
such as Twitter Facebook and YouTube and
Club Penguin should only remove speakers
and participants who are making true
threats or inciting violence the
original vote was 53% agreed that they
should only remove speakers who are you
know making threats or inciting violence
and the no vote was 25% afterwards the
yes vote went to 43% which is a change
of minus 10 and the no vote went up to
46 47 % so that means that 10 won by
gaining 20% of so I want to I want to
thank you all for you know coming out to
the first West Coast sohe forum thank
you